hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast detection of mutations
and selfie DNA from non-small cell lung
cancer using next-generation sequencing
presented by dr. Tracy Stockley
associate professor of Princess Margaret
Cancer Centre we are excited to bring
you this educational webcast
presented by lab routes and sponsored by
thermo Fisher scientific Ion Torrent
powered by semiconductor chips iron
torrent sequencing technology is simpler
faster and more cost-effective and
scalable than other benchtop
next-generation sequencing technologies
for more information about our sponsor
please visit thermo Fisher calm I am
Marjorie torres of lab foods and I'll be
your moderator for today's event before
we begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the green
human it button located in the lower lap
of the presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen will answer as many questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation also please notice that you
will be viewing the presentation in the
slide window to enlarge the window just
click on the screen icon located on the
lower right if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of the presentation window or use the
Q&A button to let us know that you're
having a problem this is an educational
webinar and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the CED button
located in the bottom left-hand corner
of your webpage and follow the process
of obtaining your credits now I'd like
to introduce dr. Tracy's broccoli
chakli is the clinical molecular
geneticist and associate director of the
molecular diagnostics division at the
Princess Margaret Cancer Centre
providing leadership within the two
divisional molecular diagnostics
laboratories for doctors broccolis full
biography please visit lab roots comm
please join me in welcoming dr. Tracey
Stockley I will now turn the
presentation over to her thank you very
much I'm very happy to present today our
work at Princess Margaret Cancer Centre
in Toronto on detection of mutations in
cell free DNA from non-small cell lung
cancer samples using the Anka mine life
uncle mine lung CF DNA assay from thermo
Fisher thank you and just to begin I
just want to present the following
disclaimer from thermo Fisher Scientific
regarding some of the presentation
within my talk so as an introduction
before I begin speaking about our
research study I just like to review
non-small cell lung cancer and
associated mutations lung cancer is the
leading cause of cancer-related
mortality in the u.s. and can be divided
into two main subtypes non-small-cell
lung cancer and small cell lung cancer
which are defined based on features of
the tumors not part of the reason that
lung cancer has such a high mortality is
that it is often detected at an advanced
stage when the cancer has spread to
other regions of the body including
brain organs such as kidney and liver or
bone non-small-cell lung cancer can also
be divided by the driver mutations that
cause activation of signaling proteins
leading to tumor Genesis mutations in
the epidermal growth factor receptor
protein EGFR tyrosine kinase are one of
the most recurrent mutations in
non-small cell lung cancer the EGFR
protein is a signaling protein located
the cell surface and has both an
extracellular domain that binds ligands
such as EGFR pardon me such as EGF at
the dermal growth factor and an
intracellular domain which causes
activation of intracellular signaling
pathways for intracellular signaling the
tyrosine kinase domain can bind ATP
which causes dimerization and auto
phosphorylation leading to proliferation
and survival there are known various
mutations in the tyrosine kinase domain
of the EGFR gene and these mutations can
cause log and independent cell
proliferation and survival when certain
occasions exist in individuals with lung
cancer they may have treatment with
tyrosine kinase inhibitors which can
bind to the tyrosine kinase domain and
prevent the ligand independent cell
proliferation and survival that is seen
in non small cell lung cancer and these
mutations are found in approximately 10
to 35 percent of non-small cell lung
cancer samples so this slide just shows
an overview then of the EGFR mutations
and their frequency in non-small cell
lung cancer at the top are mutations
that are associated with drug resistance
and at the bottom are mutations
associated with drug sensitivity so the
mutations listed on the bottom for drug
sensitivity are these mutations allow
the tyrosine kinase inhibitors to block
or inhibit the tyrosine kinase domain
functions in the EGFR protein the most
common mutations that are associated
with drug sensitivity are deletions in
exon 19 of the genes
and which occur at about 45% or the l85
8r variant which is found in exon 21 of
the gene and in addition there are
mutations that are known to cause drug
resistance that prevent the tyrosine
kinase inhibitors from carrying out
their action and the most common of
these is the t7 90m mutation which is
found in exon 20 so the EGFR resistance
mutation t7 90m the NCCN guidelines
currently recommend that samples that
have acquired resistance to tyrosine
kinase inhibitors should be tested for
the most common EGFR resistance mutation
in t7 90m the EGFR t7 honey a mutation
can be detected typically in one of two
ways either through sampling of a tumor
tissue biopsy although there are
challenges to actually obtaining tumor
tissue from some of the recurrent sites
that I mentioned or more recently by
using circulating cell free tumor DNA or
CF DNA which is DNA isolated from
peripheral blood research samples so
this slide shows an overview then of
circulating tumor cell free DNA and its
origin and how it actually presents in
peripheral circulation cell free DNA is
released from either healthy or inflamed
or disease such as tumor tissue from
cells that are undergoing apoptosis or
necrosis and so as these cells are
undergoing apoptosis or necrosis they
are releasing DNA fragments into
peripheral circulation the cell free DNA
then in peripheral circulation can be
extracted from a blood sample by
collecting the serum or the claws not
containing the cell free DNA as a way to
separate it from cells that can change
and only DNA still within the cell and
so in this way
the hope is that we can use cell-free
DNA in peripheral circulation as an
indicator of what is happening within
tumors that can't be easily accessed for
testing so to give you an overview then
of Princess Margaret Cancer Center and
our non-small cell lung cancer testing
we test typically more than 2500 non
small cell lung cancer research samples
a year for the EGFR tyrosine kinase
synthesizing and resistance mutations we
test samples of various sources
including FFPE fna or trans bronchial
needle biopsies or corneal biopsies
we have several next generation
sequencing panels for EGFR and
associated genes relevant to lung cancer
and other tumors and real-time PCR
methods for specific mutations in EGFR
gene so starting in last year in 2016 we
did begin to work up next-generation
sequencing and digital droplet PCR
methods for the EGFR t7 9dm resistance
mutation on cell free DNA and that's
what I'll talk about for the remainder
of this talk so our approach to as we
began looking at cell free DNA this this
slide just shows an overview to our
approach at Princess Margaret Cancer
Center to the pre analytic phase of cell
free DNA so we do collect the blood for
cell free DNA instruct tubes and I'll
speak a bit more about that so the those
research samples are collected instruct
tubes strict does allow a stabilization
of the cell free DNA and so the samples
can then be shipped at room temperature
which makes sending of samples between
sites much easier once the samples are
received at our site we spend to isolate
the plasma and then from the plasma
extract the cell free DNA which we then
quantify so in the in the study I'll
speak about we collected cell free DNA
instructions as we mentioned we did
collect about
20 mils of full-blood which resulted in
approximately eight to twelve mils of
plasma and from the 8 to 12
mils of plasma on the median was about
89 grams of cell-free DNA that we
extracted we chose is our cell free DNA
next generation sequencing assay the CF
DNA lung assay for uncle our NASA from
thermo Fisher and as an introduction to
the thermal Fisher sequencing system we
have also the PGM and the previous s5
version of the sequencer but currently
we're using the thermo Fisher Scientific
eye on s5 XL system the the chemistry
for sequencing on this platform is to
take your DNA fragments with adapters
attached amplify them on ions fears and
then place the ion spheres within the
sequencing plate the sequencing plate
has an eye on sensitive metal oxide
layer at the base and an electronic
transistor based sensor as well and what
happens then is as you have your bead
with your template attached to it the
reagents including deoxy TTP's and DNA
polymerase are flowed across the plate
and this extends from your template and
during that extension hydrogen ions are
released these hydrogen ions are then
detected by the plate and result in a
read of your sequence as the different
nucleotides are float across the plate
so we do like the thermo Fisher platform
because it does provide the ability to
use very low input DNA which again was
part of the reason for us to zenus while
working with cell free DNA so I'll give
a couple overview slides then just of
the thermo Fisher uncle mine CF DNA
assays there are currently three of the
assays the one that we use beyond
combine long CF DNA s
and also there are two additional assets
the : CFD and asam breast the CFD and
Iasi so I'll be speaking about the lung
CF assay the long essay includes 35
amplicons
and covers the key hotspot mutations in
the 11 genes that are listed there and
most importantly for this tox covers
EGFR and provides coverage fan of 169
hotspot snv's and insertion deletions
and I'll speak more about this but is
able to achieve down to a point one
percent limit of detection for the
hotspot variants included within that
panel and again an overview then of the
whole process of the assay that is sort
of critical parts the assay only needs
20 nanograms of input DNA to achieve a
point 1 percent limit of detection and
so this is very helpful as I mentioned
our meeting was about 80 nanograms from
two tubes of blood so from one we had
about 14 anagrams medium so this really
does allow you to test from one tube of
blood for a sample the we have run it on
as I mentioned the s5 Excel system and
we actually used the 5 v 540 chip but it
can also be run on the proton and the
PJM systems it does cover the critical
genes and the critical hotspots and
again in if you look at the bottom under
critical hotspots it does include EGFR
Fe 790 m as well as the key sensitizing
mutations l85 a tar and the exome 19
deletions and an overview end of the
workflow of the on combine CF DNA assays
as a sample comes in DNA is isolated
using your preferred method then the
library prep is carried out 20 nanograms
is the amount that we use and
recommended by the manufacturer although
I understand it can go lower than that
the template and sequencing then is can
be set up using the Iron Chef and we
sequence on the iron
sf5 and the sequencing as per usual with
the thermal Fisher platform is very
rapid and and a very flexible throughput
and we performed analysis using the
torrent suite iron reporter and I will
show that we can detect variants down to
0.1% using this platform in addition for
those labs that have access there is an
uncle mind knowledge base that allows
help with annotation and reporting of a
large number of variants so one of the
challenges in working with cell-free DNA
is the lower limit of detection and so
next generation sequencing incident in
general is known to have artifacts that
appear as variants below 5% variant
allele frequency in the results and so
if you think about a tumor that has
perhaps multiple clones within it so
perhaps you have a blue clone within
your tumor that has a common variant
within it but you also have a red clone
which has a common variant and also
additional more rare variants when you
take a sample from this tumor and tested
by next-generation sequencing you will
get both detection of the common
mutation which appears in all the reads
so for example we see that appears in
all the reads here would be a common
mutation and you would also get the sub
clone specific mutation so for example
here the T that appears in a couple
reads but the difficulty is then
detecting these this T that appears in a
couple reads from the variant that
appears in this column the C which is
just a sequencing error and so this
really is the challenge of using
next-generation sequencing for low-level
variants is trying to detect real
variants at low levels from things that
might be sequencing errors and so the
approach that the alkaline CFDA assays
take to this is to use the core
technology shown in this image so the
core technology consists of an
amplification based assay that generates
tagged DNA copy
from each strand of a DNA target
molecule and so after amplification and
tagging and sequencing the use of these
molecular tags allows the strands of the
original molecule to be associated with
each other and so this can help to
identify molecules containing a variant
from those that might be errors and not
match to the same original DNA molecule
and so in this way the athlete Lau's for
a very low level limit of detection so
this slide is data from thermo Fisher
and shows just as an example some late
stage lung cancer research samples that
were analyzed using the on combine lung
CFDA assay and you can see across these
six samples there are variants in
several different genes EGFR GP 53 etc
and in the FFPE tumor tissue tested the
variants appear at relatively high
levels and in plasma there is a much
lower level of the same variant as you
would expect because of the issue of
many other types of DNA and and fewer
actual copies of DNA being present in
the cell-free DNA extracted from plasma
you will also notice that the numbers in
bold here are the somatic mutations
present only from the tumor tissue and
not bolded are the germline mutations
which appear at relatively similar
frequencies both in the FFP and in the
plasma so overall this slide then is
showing a high correlation between the
variants called in FFPE and those called
in plasma and again another slide from
thermo Fisher this was data from an aqua
network consortium where they had to use
this assay and assess the limit of
detection using a very helpful cell free
DNA reference that The Horizon CF DNA
multi
flex reference set and this reference
that includes the eight variants across
that are shown across the top in gray
and what in the study was diluted to the
amount shown on the left point one one
and five percent as well as assessing
100 percent wild-type control so you can
see that the the a save is CFD ma lung
assay performed very well to detect
these eight variants at the levels that
approximate what was expected based on
dilution of the reference that put into
the athlete okay so now to get into our
research study at Princess Margaret
Cancer Center so our study originally
started with 63 non small cell lung
cancer research samples from peripheral
blood that were collected in stretch
cell free DNA blood collection tubes and
all 63 of these research samples were
taken from individuals who had
previously had tumor tissue tested and
were positive for EGFR sensitizing
mutations most typically the exon 19
deletion or the l85 8r mutation and as I
had mentioned we obtained about 8 mm of
the plasma from 20 mils of peripheral
blood and we use the current circulating
nucleic acid kit to extract the
cell-free DNA the concentration that we
obtained was ranged between 0.2 to 26
nanograms for my clear and the total DNA
amount median was so many nanograms but
a range of about 8 to 1 point 6
micrograms so just a comment about the
collecting peripheral blood sample
research samples for CF DNA we do
currently use these strict tube mainly
because the samples are so rare and
precious and we want to maximize our
chance of having cell-free DNA obtained
the stretch kids do have preservatives
within them that stabilize the nucleated
blood cells and so
prevent release of genomic DNA from
those cells and we also find that being
based in Canada and having samples sent
from some distance in some cases these
the the samples are stable for up to 14
days at room temperature as per the
manufacturer and based on this
publication does reduce the need for
immediate plasmic preparation after
collection so I'll show our CF DNA sa
from analysis from the thermo Fisher
assay but I wanted to first just present
our comparison so for these 63 samples
we did do a comparison between the
droplet digital PCR and next-generation
sequencing using the CF DNA long lasting
so just to give you an overview of the
droplet digital PCR that we used droplet
digital PCR is another way to get a
detection of low levels of mutations if
you think first about a typical PCR
reaction you have many samples many
particles within your samples that are
wild-type and this may be in vast excess
of the molecules within your sample that
are mutant and yet when you take a
regular PCR and amplify this tube you
end up with an average signal so that
you basically drowned out the signal
from your mutant what digital droplets
PCR will do instead is to actually
separate your PCR reaction into many
individual droplets and so the starting
material is segregated into droplets and
then amplified and this allows you to
then calculate using statistics the the
number of the original mutant the mutant
molecule that was in your starting
sample and the type of results that you
get from DD PCR are shown here the most
important most important data is shown
within these three quadrants the mutant
quadrant that are celled molecules
part of me droplets containing only
mutant molecules this quadrant which are
droplets containing only wild-type and
this this quadrant which are droplets
containing both mutant and wild type
molecules and this slide then just shows
what you would expect from various
diminishing amounts of mutant molecules
one percent all the way down to point
zero one and it's by assessment of the
molecules that appear within this window
that you can estimate the amount of
mutant molecules in your starting
starting sample so for DNA PCR we
validated we could detect down to 0.1
percent mutant but really we validated
it to be very reproducible at 0.5
percent so that was our limit of
detection for the DD PCR assay for the
t7 IBM mutation in EGFR so then when we
started with the using the cell-free DNA
long assay we did start as recommended
testing the horizon see if they may
multiplex reference set that I had
mentioned before and so again this
sample had eight variants that we
diluted to the different percentages
shown on the Left we did have very good
detection and very good correlation with
what was expected for this sample the
only one that we found we could not
detect a point one percent was the EGFR
exon 19 dilution we weren't very
concerned with this though because we
did know from our GDP see our experience
that 0.1 percent was hard for us to
achieve every single time and this was
really just our first assessment of the
assay and so we felt with some
experience we were likely to be able to
improve that and so the spec to the the
63 samples that I mentioned we had
tested for this study this gives you an
overview then of the samples tested by
DD PCR and overview of their results for
pass and fail and the samples tested by
the lung CF DNA uncle minus a so as I
mentioned four GPCR we only had set up
the athlete for EGFR t 790 m for each
for Dede PCR each SAT is one specific
mutation unless you multiplex we hadn't
multiplex and so our duty PCR only
picked up EGFR t7 90 M whereas for the
alkaline long we were testing obviously
the 11 genes and hotspots within those
the amount of input DNA we used was the
same for both the sensitivity for DD PCR
we really felt was the point five
percent and for all combined we had a
sensitivity down to 0.1% an interesting
thing that we found though was that for
DV PCR of the sixty-three that we tested
three of them were insufficient so we
only tested 60 in total although 6011
actually failed on DD PCR and 49 passed
the failure on GDP Sarah was
reproducible for us so if we went back
to the original sample it still failed
we're still trying to investigate why
that might be but it does seem to be
something in here in the original sample
that prevents it from carrying on in DD
PCR it really prevents formation of the
beads whereas for the aankhen line long
CF in a NGSS a we had a very good pass
rate 60 of 61 actually passed into or
insufficient for them so just to give
you a quick overview then of the sort of
key run metrics across the runs that we
did for this set of research samples the
key metrics are across the top here and
the runs are shown in sequential order
from our first run to the sauce so to
begin I just want to mention the first
run we were using the 540 chip on the s5
XL and to start we weren't sure what
dodging would be appropriate so we
started with eight samples but clearly
we had really a lot more capacity and so
for the next two runs two to five we
increase that to 16 samples per chip
which seemed to give a lot better closer
to the total reads that you would expect
on that kind of chip capacity
and I really feel that sort of by the
time we got to our fifth run our
expertise was much better at just using
the panel and so we had you know a very
good total reads and total bases called
and loading and lo polyclonal etc some
of the metrics that are shown in red
here we're a bit less than we might have
expected but it did improve with our
experience and overall the data from all
of these runs was very usable the the
B's metrics still were in a very usable
range so we have no concern with the
performance of the asset and this slide
then shows more detailed metrics
specific to each of the 60 samples just
as an example of things like the mean
depth and the coverage of these
different samples and so again all of
these metrics for the vast majority of
the samples were met or exceeded what
was recommended I did highlight at the
bottom two samples one of which failed
which I called 61 in this slide and then
one which was suboptimal so didn't quite
meet the metrics that that we would have
expected or that the other samples met
but still the data from that sample was
was still quite reliable in comparison
to DD PCR so I did mention and
previously that we had a number of
samples that failed on DD PCR and that's
worked well in the on combine assay of
and this was 11 of the 60 samples of
these four were actually positive for
the EGFR t7 on a.m. on the CFDA and GSS
a with a range between 0.1 percent to
two almost two percent and so this just
is you know sort of supports the idea
that we may be able to detect variance
from the on combine CFD and a long assay
that we wouldn't be able to detect using
only DD PCR and this slide then is a
comparison of EGFR to 790 m results from
both the DD PCR and the
come on from the DD PCR we had and sorry
just to also remind you this is of the
49 samples that were positive on both
assays 49 being the number that was
positive on DD PCR so of the ones the 22
that were positive on PDP CR allele
frequency is shown here 47 9 a.m. all of
these were also positive on the alkaline
long CF DNA assay and the ones that we
thought were sort of low positive a bit
below what we would normally call from
Beauty PCR also positive on the outcome
line and in addition the GDP CR would
give us negative results for 25 and all
combined only gave us negative results
for 15 and so this really means that we
had 9 additional samples that had piece
of a 9 DM detected on cell-free DNA by
the danke mine lungs CFDA assay but not
by DD PCR so these nine samples then
were had EGFR t7 IBM in the range of 0.1
to 2.6 percent so certainly some of
these may be below what we would expect
to be able to detect by DD PCR but
certainly some are in the range that we
would have expected to find by DD PCR
and so again this shows sort of the
additional benefit that we found in
using the NGS approach to CF DNA and
because of the the difference between
the allele frequencies of Gd P CR and
NGS we just wanted to compare how will
the t7 9 a.m. variant allele frequencies
compared between these two assays and so
this graph shows the variant allele
frequency percent from the Uncle - a on
the y-axis and then the variant allele
frequency from DD PCR on the x-axis and
there was very good correlation between
those two and so we you know we felt
that this did sort of support the
variant allele frequency calling between
these two assays
I did mention previously that we
appreciated that there was additional
genes within the lung CF DNA NGS assay
that we could also test at the same time
as testing for EGFR and this just shows
some of the variants that we also found
in these samples in additional genes so
some of the EGFR results are listed here
but in addition we found variants in an
RAF pik3ca camera and k rest and at a
very similar type of level that we found
for EGFR so for many of these variants
we could detect it down to 0.1%
so as I mentioned one of the real
challenges of CF DNA is actually being
able to achieve a very low limit
sensitivity a very low limit of
detection and so there are certain
criteria within the assay that help you
understand if your data is of a high
enough quality to have achieved 0.1%
sensitivity and those criteria that the
key criteria are shown here the mean
depth which is recommended for 0.1%
sensitivity to be greater than 20,000
median molecular coverage which is
recommended to be greater than 1,500 and
then targets greater than point eight
median molecular coverage which is
recommended to be greater than 80
percent and these three criteria are
available on the sheets the user sheets
that can be obtained from thermo Fisher
and so in our data then I'm the 61 that
that performed that we had results from
in the NGS we had very good very good
meeting of these metrics limits so even
for the most strict criteria which is
the targets greater than point 8 media
molecular coverage we still had 52 of
our 61 samples that actually met or
exceeded that so we felt that in the
majority of our samples we were able to
meet the metrics that allowed us to
achieve a point 1 percent sensitivity
and overall then this just shows our
uncle mine lung CFDA as a result of the
60 that we tested 37 were positive and
of these 37 36 of these also had an EGFR
sensitizing mutation typically the
excellent een deletion or l85 8 are one
of them that actually had t7 RDM causes
it was positive at a low level of 0.1%
we did not detect any other EGFR variant
so that may just represent you know just
some difference in the ability of detect
eat all of the EGFR variants at that low
level and 23 of the samples then were
negative 47 idea of the other EGFR
variants we found in the two seminar am-
samples we did confirm that there were
other EGFR mutations within those
samples so for example EXO 19 deletion
al v 8 v alpha 8 5 8 r or g7 19's and so
this is useful because it does still
indicate that the tumor was releasing
cell-free DNA within 2 peripheral
circulation but that t7 90m wasn't
detected so by including these
additional sensitizing mutations within
the test it does give you some some
measure of confidence that the tumor was
releasing cell-free DNA which would be
different than if you had a completely
negative test result on on an assay and
finally as I mentioned that we did
detect variants and other genes most
commonly these were variance in tp53 but
we did find one variant in M wrasse in
one variant in pik3ca and so the
potential benefit of NGS n over using a
single mutation as they like DD PCR is
detection of variants in these other
genes
and so finally then just to summarize
our use of the uncommon lung cell-free
DNA assay at Princess Margaret Cancer
Center we did find that it was very
accurate at low level inputs of DNA we
did only use 20 nanograms but we were
able to detect down 2.1 percent in a
majority of our samples it worked
extremely well on on the s5 XL and
throughput was very amenable to the
amount that we had to test and it had
good coverage of relevant genes and
critical hotspots and then finally just
as a thank you to members of our group
and collaborators at Princess Margaret
Cancer Centre in particular I'd like to
thank Hongzhang from the advancement
like a Diagnostics lab who saw the
technical oversaw the technical work for
this and to thank thermo Fisher for
their support with this study thank you
Thank You dr. Stockley for that
informative presentation it's time for
Q&A if you have a question you'd like to
ask please do so now just click on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window type your
questions into the box that appears on
your screen and click on the send button
one answer as many questions as we have
time for if we're unable to get you to
your questions dr. Stockley will follow
up with you via email updated
presentation let's get started our first
question is what acids was used with the
BG PCR solution
sure thanks Marjorie um yes so we it was
just one of the pre-designed essays from
the vendor so we used the I read system
so it was one of the bio-rad digital PCR
assays thank you and the next question
is what differences were notable to you
between the GG PCR and n gs workflow
sure
so dd PCR is a fairly simple workflow
and and so an NGS I think just because
of the way the technology works always
takes a longer time than DD PCR but I
would say that the workflow again we use
the chef which did really help set up
for the assay and you know just
achieving a fairly good throughput for
the NGSS e in general
thank you you mentioned the input DNA
amount used for both DD PCR and NGOs for
20 nanograms did you have an opportunity
to test at a lower input amount of DNA
yes we didn't at this point it's still a
fairly small number of samples that we
used so we yes we haven't tried anything
less than that although I am aware that
single Fisher does does mention that it
can be used with less DNA but we didn't
ourselves try that for some of the
cell-free horizon control that we use we
actually used a little bit more but in
general we just stayed with the
recommended 20 nanograms okay and the
next question is do you have any idea
why you had a high rate of failure of CF
DNA testing on DD PCR you mentioned 18
percent yes I'm very interested in this
and if anyone is also experiencing this
I think we would really like to hear
about it we're really we're really not
sure I think part of the problem with
working with cell free DNA is that you
don't have a lot to go back and and do
this sort of experiment you would want
to do or you could repeat things and try
different conditions although the only
clue that we have at this point is that
if we go back to that same sample that
same extraction of cell free DNA we do
still get a fail on a DD PCR so you know
we're trying to investigate if it is
something either specific to the samples
or something within the extraction
whatever it is it still allows those
samples though to go on to NGS so it
must be something specific to the DD PCR
which may not be a surprise because
there probably are some just issues
inherent in forming the beads and
getting them term aid ok the next
question is our applicant size and
primer design between uncommon assay MDD
PCR for detection of t7 I am identical
or similar
yes I don't actually know that off the
top of my head I would think though just
knowing in general the size of the uncle
mine and panels and the amplicon lines
probably they are are similar yes but I
I'm sorry I don't know the exact size
I'll top my head
okay the next question is what is the
typical fragment size of CFDA do you
need a different method to extract of
abstract CF DNA than the one used in the
intact cell yes you do you definitely
need a different method to extract the
CF DNA it has to be a method that can
you know work well on a very dilute
amount of DNA in a sample and then the
other question was about what is the
size of the cell-free DNA so that is a
no number i-it's about a hundred and
thirty base pairs because it is really
the amount of DNA that is wrapped around
a nucleosome which is the fragment
between minik Lee films allow for
digestion so that is a known number and
I think in general the majority of is
about 130 base pairs okay the next
question is what extraction kit was
utilized to extract the CF DNA yes we
use the kaijin the collagen Kim that's
right Kaizen kit I think it's called the
Chi am circulating a cell-free DNA kit
that we used
okay the next question is how do you
quantify CF DNA just using our our sort
of standard quantitation it is double
stranded so does work in many of the
ways you would normally assess DNA the
next question is are we able to get
access to this test now is there a cost
to requesting sentry we are just still
developing it as a you know for research
use so I can only speak to our Center
and I'm not sure if it's being offered
in in other places but no not not at our
Center currently
okay I would like to once again thank
dr. Stockley for her presentation do you
have any final comment no just that I
would like to thank Sarah Fisher for
their support of both for allowing us
early access to this essay and for
giving us a chance to talk about it
today thank you thank you once again to
dr. Stockley I would also like to thank
lab roots and thermo Fisher Scientific
Ion Torrent for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand from viewing through December
28th 2017 you will receive an email from
lab roots letting me know when this
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining us and we hope to see you
again soon goodbye